my Flex I don't know I have no idea uh using 85
flex on my stick but I cut it down a little bit so
it's a little probably a little stiffer than that
why do I use that it's just kind of the one that
that works for me as a centerman you got to take
face off so it needs to be a little bit stiffer
but you still want to be able to shoot the puck
so you need a stick that kind of lets you uh lets
you do everything honestly have no clue you hear
guys that are know everything about their sticks
I don't know much I'm thinking it's like 87 but
I have no clue 87 because I feel like today's you
can use the flex a lot more than you think like
back a few years ago everybody mostly played with
100 Flex because the harder the the better the
cooler you would be but now you actually have a
chance to use the flex and I think going down
helps you get the shot off quicker 80. I like
it whippy just for like a wrist shot snapshot
I like it pretty whippy so it can kind of use
the stick a bit to kind of whip the putt uh 75.
I've always kind of used the low flax I use 65
like my first three years and then those started
getting a little too hippy and then I went up to
75 and it's kind of what I like the most Flex on
my stick is 70. I don't know I just like a little
whippier and maybe it's 75 I think it's 75 but I
have like the big paddle my blade so it's bottom
heavy I don't know break up probably a few more
six than I would like but oh 75 I played with it
for maybe five years six years I'm probably gonna
switch it a little stiffer 180 maybe I don't know
I like the pretty low Flex it's easier to pass
and shoot restart on my stacks I guess 77 but
like cut down so probably like a 81. just not
that big and there's a good Flex for me nothing
nothing too crazy about it uh 80 82. I just been
I I always use uh kind of soft sticks I like the
the whippier sticks and started when I was young
at like 50 or something I just worked my way up
stopped at 82 I think get a good feel in the steak
and and I can use a lot of whip in the stick when
I shoot the puck so 82. it's it's pretty flexible
you know like you can you can Flex it so you don't
have to go hard to to shoot high and it's more
quick 82. I feel like it's a good combination
of not being too wippy but enough that I can lean
on it and I feel like the sniffer your stick is
the easier it is to stick handle so just try and
find a good mix I feel like you got to be able
to shoot the puck still in 87 might be a little
too stiff for me and I've tried 77 too whippy so
82 is perfect my Flex on my stick is 82. uh why I
have no clothes just the one that um I mean I was
trying out one day and I liked it I haven't really
switched it probably been about five or six years
80 flex and I cut it down so probably gets to 85
90 Flex so like that the flex not too hard not too
soft so uh 85. I don't know I just found that's uh
what works best for me I would say it was always
higher and it's kind of slowly gone down over the
last like five years it went from 95 to 90 now
we're at 85 So eventually it'll stay somewhere
hopefully it's there it's not all for shooting
like battles that all that kind of matters with it
too so can't go too wippy where you don't really
have the strength to weigh on it 85 because I
used to be old school you know 37 years old so
I was still in the way when I became Pro of the
110 115 why your Clapper is a magnificent but
then your restart is pretty much then hockey is
getting so fast and you need to have whippiness
to be able to the past to go leave your stick as
fast as possible and your shot as fast as possible
and uh I mean it's only some players they get to
take clappers all the time me if I take a Clapper
somebody messed up on the ice because it shouldn't
happen my stick is 85 and just I don't know just
a quick shot obviously I think it would be
I'll be even better on Face Off I would have a
higher Flex so but you gotta choose 87 90 those
two it's 87 stick and I cut it a little bit so
it's something I don't know exactly what number
Flex is it but I started with stick 87 and it's
still soft after a couple of shots so that's
my go-to my Flex is 87 but I cut it down a
little bit so it's probably like a 90. I think
I need a stiffer Flex as a centerman and yeah
I've just been kind of using that Flex for a
while so I'm used to it uh 95. I cut it down
a little bit so it kind of gets a little stiffer
with that and tried to go with beer and it just
doesn't apply to my game uh I use 95 Flex I like
it a pretty stiff stick I still cut it down after
that too so I have a nine to five place because
I feel like it's a mix between uh you can still
shoot good and still battle it pretty good uh 95.
uh 95 just uh it just worked out 100 would be way
too stiff 80 87 was too whippy so just had to go
with something in between uh it's 95 I like it a
little stiffer I feel the puck a little bit better
that way it's kind of always what I used it's hard
to switch it takes a lot of wear and tear and
better for one-timers as well a little stiffer
stick 95. just stick battles face-offs catching
passes one timers a hundred you know I used to
have a flexier stick I feel like the feel on a on
a stiffer stick is a lot better for passing for
handling it and you know my thought is always
you know when you're getting into a situation
where I really need to lean on your stick and get
a shot off you know you're never short of power
there's times where you know in practice you're
like well geez like this is way too way too stiff
because you get a little tired and you're
like I don't want to shoot a puck but when
I get when you get to a game I feel like you want
a little a little stiffer because I feel like you
get better feedback from a stiffer stick 100
like it that way I like the stuffiness of it
and that just fits molds my game 100 Flex um
it just feels right and I'm pretty heavy so
it just kind of matches and feels right for me
a hundred I don't know like I always think you
go a little lower but you know for the Face-Off
and for that I like to be like really stiff and
I feel like after games go is even it's always
going to loosen up so I like it but I'm super
easy I'm I got same stick I think for my uh
16 17 like the everything same they just you
know the design and stuff is changing but
I'm really simple guy and I'm not really
or changing stuff uh 102. I just always used a
stiffer shaft and yeah my dad bought me a 102
Flex by accident when I was younger and I just
kind of I liked it better catching passes stick
hailing and shooting so just kind of stuck
with it 100. well it's a little bit stiffer
and I think just taking face-offs and I used
a two-piece stick prior to that one of the few
guys that had the shaft and Blades still when I
I think I played with that for three four years
so yeah I think a lot of younger guys have been
used to using one pieces and are used to probably
a little bit less flex but I've always used a
bit more of a stiffer stick 122. I don't know
what I had to start when I came in but probably
102 but you know being a taller guy the more
muscles I put on the stronger the steak has become
so uh you know 122 has been a good flex and feels
like I can get my shots away quickly and hard
when when needed to so uh good one timer stick
but the goal is I don't know if you really have
taxes uh I don't even think goalies have flexes on
their stick so I I have no idea I think 85 maybe
just that's how they made it when I got it sorry
oh really I don't even know what mine would be
[Music]